do you know that worldwide obesity has  increased tripled since 1975.  in 2016 about 1.9 billion adults were  overweight and 650 millions were obese  and the shocking news came in 2020 where  39 million children were found to be  overweight or obese  and that's shocking  obesity is life-threatening because it  increases the risk of heart attack  stroke type 2 diabetes and cancer  but what is the reason behind obesity  obviously eating more sugary and  processed food exercising less because  we have sedentary lifestyle all these  results in obesity  but because of obesity is beyond  overeating  there could be genetic and epigenetic  reasons behind obesity  but lifestyle modification and proper  exercise can prevent obesity and that's  pretty assuring  learn more by subscribing